foreign
[Music]
right good thank you very much
hey if you've got your own Sensei to
correct your uh your postures your
anything else to do with technique what
I'm going to show you tonight is some of
my Aikido
it might it'll be different to your
iwama style but
um don't worry about
what you're doing think about your own
Aikido all right
and and do that okay so another one okay
please
okay
um
all I would say on this is that when you
get to here don't try and go here
if I tried this on Stuart I wouldn't get
anywhere you've got to lift the chin
okay
okay please
yeah anyone anyone
um
but when I get to here
you know I sometimes like to do it like
cutting with a sword
okay cut straight down through the body
that's fine
up he's already gone there and so
he's off posture at that point okay
so you can do
the throw away
but you can also
come straight down
okay here
twice the backy
and on the other side
yeah
here
now Thai sabaki
and up the other side
and your name
is
all right oh I've got a technique there
shake hands here
if we can do that now look
gravity Cola spin him around
and you've got a
choke
once more
Shake
step grab the back of the collar
turn him around you've got a choke
if you do a technique correctly
as I understand it
there isn't supposed to be a counter to
that technique all right
for instance if
you can do the tiny coat of guys okay
yeah Tower
there shouldn't be a counter to that
okay
but we need to be aware of it yeah
if the code of guys isn't coming on
then what you've got to do is you're
going to straighten your arm
sorry yeah
whoops yeah
straighten your arm here
whoops
and you can do lots of different
techniques from the end of it yeah
straighten your arm
so you're doing a counter
to the Cody guy from Nick Hill
okay you're doing liquor here
again
yeah there
okay
you see it yet
here
we're all taught
when we do Nick Hill
here this
business
all right well we taught you for a
reason
because we're taught
that when we're doing the kill
we're cutting through here so we we make
a hand blade here okay
we've got the nickel
right
but
it does layers on to counter technique
so
for me when you do
Nick Gill
yeah
you need to
not do that except learning learning yes
always because you've got to start your
basic somewhere
but
grab
grab as soon as you can
yeah sorry
yeah
you don't need much you almost do it
blindfolded
okay
here
now we do it from here okay you're going
to Nick you
thank you
you don't even you don't need to even
see it you know if your hand goes there
it's it's on straight away
all right this is ryoti Dory here okay
[Music]
yeah
I was taught very early on in my Ikea
career that either
I move
d
Hold On Tight give us a bit give me
something here
there
or
UK moves
so
he's got to move
we got there in the end didn't we we got
there
down
this goes through the hip here this one
comes up
push through with the hip
turn
up I'm sorry go this way
here
up
and turn
got it we're in uh whatever's gecko
honey here
this comes up
cuts down to the hip this one Cuts up
push through
all those okay was moving I was staying
static they buy my sensei in Japan who
was a contemporary of Saito
so he also did lots of other weapon
things
um grab a Joel
or else you can if you don't want to you
can watch but uh
this is going to be a
a flash
The Flash through it so um
if you don't know it don't worry about
it okay
so sweat yourselves out
okay
try and try and copy me now yeah all
right sorry
I'm lost
I've lost myself
so I'll put it in the right hand shall I
um
pick up your Joe
and do Subaru number one
okay
up
and
yeah
and up again
and
three
again
one
two
three
now two skis
four
five
so in a matter of
about a minute and a half we've done 20
percent of the josephery of the 25 count
one
two
three
four five
again
one
two
two three
four
four five
again
have we broken a light already okay do
it
yeah it's going and count
good good
so from five
okay I've got to remember now what we'll
do oh six
seven
eight okay yeah five five six
eight
sorry six
seven
[Music]
eight
one more from this side
six
seven
eight
nine
nine ten
eleven now the hand change here all
right
where are we ten
at ten
when we go to eleven there's a hand
change here okay change from here
to here
so
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
and
ski and hand change
and now you're going to do Hustle
yeah
okay
I got them didn't it
hey so from six six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven with a hand change
12.
there's another hand change here you can
just all right
from here to here
because you're going into 13
and
15.
look
forward
no I did I did that I looked six
seven
eight
nine
ten eleven
twelve
thirteen
fourteen
fifteen
who's gonna try from one to
15 then
wait as well you should
Do It Go on the two of you then go on
two
two three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine ten
eleven
12 13.
. 15 good
um remember number number eight all
right number eight is not ski all right
it's um six seven it's a turnover you
know but okay turnover
that's good it's good
all right where are we we're at uh 15
wasn't it
the 15 was um
15 were there yeah
16 so it's a hand change again
16.
17.
20.
21.
and I've miscounted somewhere I've
miscounted okay
you'll tell me where I've gone wrong in
a minute yeah
oh yes I missed out how's the guy she
didn't die yeah yeah thank you very much
Stuart so sorry
14 15.
16.
17 now hustle guys again hand change
yeah watch what you're doing with it
20.
21.
I'm still I'm still wrong because I'm
one out now
15 16
17.
18 19 20.
22 23
. we'll start from one
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
twelve
thirteen
fourteen
fifteen
sixteen
seventeen
eighteen
nineteen
twenty
Twenty One
no
I'm wrong again aren't I
stuff
because um 19 is one movement isn't it
yeah
where are we
again from the beginning
one
one two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
eleven
twelve
thirteen
fourteen
fifteen
sixteen
seventeen
eighteen
nineteen
twenty
Twenty One
.